for today we're very pleased to have us
our second invited speaker Richard
Scioscia who's the chief scientist at
Salesforce which it actually also has a
lot more connection to this class
because for several years
Richard was involved either as
instructor or Co instructor in teaching
this material at Stanford so he sort of
knows the course pretty well and so
today he's going to be talking about
some of the challenges and recent work
in doing multitask learning in meta
language processing so welcome Richard
thank you
hello everybody excited to be here today
about what we in short called Decca NLP
I want to first give a big shout out to
Brian McCann he's the first author of
this paper and I've pitched this idea to
a lot of people in the last like three
to four years and most people were like
this is too much pre-processing because
you're trying to do 10 different tasks
in one model that's sort of where the
Decathlon wording comes in but he really
stuck to it did all the pre-processing
and all the things that you now know
like tokenization it turns out a lot of
different datasets
have a different conception of what a
word is as was in two words or one word
and things like that and that changes
how you write all your evaluation
scripts and all of that so Brian is a
really phenomenal researcher with us in
the group
nitesh has helped us a lot on the
optimization side of this and then
Simon's a director of research has done
a lot of really phenomenal work it's
kind of helpful and pretty much all our
projects so I'm gonna tell you a couple
of different lines of reasoning that led
us to this idea of multitask learning
and the first one was sort of trying to
take a step back and looking at the
field and I noticed not like that much
of a historical class but basically
pre-2010 most natural language
processing had kind of these very hand
designed features and we basically just
had machine learning kind of learned
weights in the optimization procedure
for these human designed features and so
in 2010 Chris and I and others sort of
started
work and deep learning for future
learning so everything was a ward vector
now I can back propagate into them and
actually learn those representations and
I think currently we're kind of in a
state where we do a lot of deep
architecture engineering for specific
paths and you've seen this already you
have like in any our model you have a
question answering model you have a
translation model and we're basically
now each of these communities has at
least converged on is probably some kind
of neural network but there's still a
lot of different kinds of architectures
of these neural networks that you're
working on for each different tasks and
so the question is I okay we're going to
probably do that for another couple of
years because we're making good progress
but what's sort of next on the research
side and what I actually love about this
class so much is that you go from like
maybe not knowing much about NLP at all
so you can basically understand the
state-of-the-art research papers as they
come out now and this this is one of
those so why why not continue to work in
this multitask regime in some ways I
feel like the community is a little bit
like this cute dog where we kind of
randomly restart after every project and
it's kind of clear to me that if you
have a lot of training data and you
define a specific data set and task on
that data set you start to architect
your engineer on your model to Hill
Climb on a particular metric or
leaderboard or no publications or
products or whatever it is then as long
as your data set has roughly a good
representative set of a thousand times
the number of output classes that you
have you probably get it into a regime
where you're in the 80 to 90% accuracy
or f1 where you're basically doing
pretty okay and of course no when you
look at syringe instance imagenet you
have a thousand different classes in
computer vision thousand different
classes each has a thousand images so if
you have roughly a million images you do
pretty well and in machine translation
ideally you know I have many more if
like hundreds of thousands of words you
want many millions of examples of each
of the word in their words in their
context and of course you know but the
caveat is machine translation doesn't
work to the level of humans but it works
well enough to have it at least in
products and even the best human
translators used
sort of a pre translation and then sort
of clean it up and so it's also clear to
me that in this regime and if we want to
get to sort of more general
AI features we need to have some kind of
more continuous learning of a single
model because if we keep restarting at
every project we're never going to get
to a single model it kind of encompasses
more and more of the complexity of
natural language and when I say we start
from random you of course know that
that's not quite true because we do have
some things that we pre train namely
word vectors and in computer vision we
have even more things and so in some
ways that is an aspiring ideal for NLP
because in Russia division you would be
kind of crazy to not use some kind of
convolutional neural network that is
preached for it has been pre trained on
some kind of tasks like image net when
you start with your project and try to
classify objects or object detection and
a lot of other things and in some ways
that the whole community could get
behind it very quickly because I mean
you know once it worked reasonably well
because there was sort of a single
blocking task in computer vision if you
can't even tell apart a dog from a cat
from a house doesn't really make sense
to think of even larger vision projects
and an NLP we've had a lot of success
with word vectors you know a lot of
those now and it started to sort of just
a small window based approach we were to
Veck and glove then we had context
vectors that were trained on machine
translation but basically instead of
just having a single set of words we
actually pre trained some of the LS TM s
that came on top of those word vectors
and the way we trained that was also
actually Brian McCann paper on
contextual vectors was with machine
translation and then Elmo kind of
replaced machine translation with
language modeling which of course even
matters even more training data and it
still tells you a lot and kind of
captures in some ways a more complex
version of distributional sort of
hypotheses that we had and simpler word
vectors and in bird not quite a language
model but also kind of trying to predict
words in their context but pre-training
a lot more layers and a lot deeper
networks and so we see the success of
pre training a certain set of weights
and so the question is why not try to
pre train the entire model as including
put your softmax your pointer mechanisms
and everything and then just taking a
completely pre-trained model and trying
to do something and that is kind of the
goal that we have and so we sort of
asked ourselves why hasn't this happened
why are we you know the first to think
about like trying to pre train the
entirety of the model the encoders and
decoders and outputs and everything and
I think part of it is that NLP requires
a lot of different kinds of reasoning
you're seeing many of them already you
have some logical reasoning like 550
people in this room 25 leave are there
still people in the room and you kind of
logically can answer that question you
have lots of different kinds of
linguistic and emotional reasoning
sentiment analysis you know this is a
typical Nicolas Cage movie and then you
need to know that that's probably a
negative review unless you like go
sketch movies um no judgement and you
know visual types of reasoning and so on
and so I think partly because of that
complexity in the beginning to feel
didn't really make much progress and now
and then kind of separate it and I think
in some cases kind of artificially
separated into all these separate tasks
like you have named entity recognition
and part of speech tagging and semantic
role labeling and and so on and in some
ways and it sounds kind of snarky but
you know it made a lot of sense at a
time and it allowed us to make a lot of
progress in the community but basically
we started chasing these benchmarks and
all these different communities kind of
started going off in their own ways and
you even have some communities that say
we do general question-answering and
there's literally workshops and general
question-answering and when I asked the
organizers can I ask your model what the
sentiment is of this tweet they're like
no that that sentiment analysis go to
that different workshop it's down down
the hall but I'm like that's it that's a
question why can't you answer it in the
general question answering workshop and
so a lot of people then say well if you
want to work on more general stuff it
has to be an unsupervised kind of task
and the future will not be supervised
I don't think NLP will be completely
unsupervised and we won't solve it
completely unsupervised because in the
end language has a lot of supervision
for people and I think for for systems
also and you won't you know if you have
a child and it's in the jungle probably
developed pretty good visual cortex by
itself but it won't develop
which by itself and then and and also
like I think if you'll just allow a eyes
to talk to one another it makes very
little sense for them to try to come up
with as inefficient of a communication
protocol as humans have of you know
sequential processing of language
because algorithms and computers could
there's no supervision of human language
they could just communicate in much more
efficient ways with one another so I
think it's fairly clear we need a lot of
supervision in NLP and so basically all
of this has led us to trying to think
about a unified multi task model for a
lot of different NLP tasks by the way if
you have any questions just raise your
hand make this very interactive
basically we want this unified model to
decide how to transfer knowledge and not
have it sort of be manually assigned
like in most cases when you design your
project you say oh well I know that name
entity recognition and part of speech
tagging help each other because once you
know something is a noun then it's more
likely that it's also a named entity and
in this case we want to basically allow
for this single unified model to know
itself how to do domain adaptation and
how to share the weights and that will
hopefully then lead to a lot of transfer
learning and zero short learning
capabilities I also think that if we get
to this sort of hard goal of having a
single single unified multi task model
then we'll be able to more easily
adapted to new tasks and we'll be also
able to deploy it in production more
quickly if nowadays you want to build a
little squirrel detector and connected
to your sprinkler system you can just
download some off-the-shelf software and
it will basically kind of work that is
not the case if you try to do a pretty
complex language project or you want to
translate into some completely new
language or you know analyze some
website and then do something else
afterwards so you also when you actually
try to deploy and use these kinds of
tools and companies you'll realize that
there are a lot of different kinds of
groups there's a search group and the
chat law team and the translation team
and and the social sentiment analysis
team and they all use different models
and they all deploy different models and
they all have to build a lot of overhead
into the core of the or around that core
of an AI model
so basically lastly it was sort of what
we had with with this dog I think that
once we have this unified model it will
also be a first step to being able to
then continually learn this and just
have a single model that just gets
better and better over time and starts
to capture more and more of the
complexity of language all right any
questions around sort of the motivation
high-level all right so then it's sort
of the question how do we actually make
that happen and then we I first sort of
sat down and looked at like the general
sort of formats of all the tasks that
you may experience in as fast and that
NLP sort of has as a field in general
and I think they can broadly classify it
be classified in these three different
categories sequence tagging you already
know things like an NER or aspect
specific sentiment where in a specific
context you want to classify if a word
is positive or negative and then text
classification just a single label for
the entire piece of text and then
sequence the sequence a lot of different
you know problems fall into that and I
actually personally love these three
particular tasks machine translation
summarization question answering because
they are immediately useful there you
don't have to explain somebody over why
do you need to cement the grow label or
parser if you're a layman and you you
know on the internet you understand
immediately why it's useful to do
summarization question answering or
translation and an improvement in those
tasks kind of immediately translates
into better products and people being
able to communicate better and more
efficiently of language so that kind of
analysis led us to think about these
what I call three equivalent super tasks
of NLP and basically they are language
modeling question answer that question
answering and dialogue systems language
modeling basically trying to predict
predict the next word you've already
worked on that and usually it's only
used to rescore or basically a pre train
these days but really if you ask you a
question and then you try to predict the
next couple of words then that is
so language modeling and if you're able
to predict the next couple of words
after question like what were the name
entities in this sentence and then you
just generate you know Dresden was a
location richard was a person and
whatnot then you can kind of cast almost
all of these tasks into language
modeling
similarly question answering you can ask
any kind of question what is the
translation what's the summary and so on
and then with dialogue right now it's
kind of tricky because there are no
really good dialogue datasets out there
and a lot of times you want some
interaction you have to run user studies
and most of the existing NLP tasks would
basically be pretty short one-step
dialogues like what are the name entity
tags you give them and that's it so it's
a little bit overkill and because of
that we basically converged on question
answering as our main formalism and here
is now an overview of the ten different
tasks that we have and we cast all of
them ask question answering these are
literally the training the format of the
training data set and eventually also
the way we formulate the test set and
you'll see basically for every single
task you have a context as some kind of
document could be a Wikipedia article it
could be a tweet a longer document
whatever and you ask a question about it
and you want to generate an answer and
I'm actually I'm curious if you can
think of any task in NLP that couldn't
be formulated in this kind of structure
so let's go over some of these the first
one is sort of the standard tasks that
you're all familiar with now the squad
Stanford question answering data set
where the answer is essentially a phrase
somewhere in the context but then the
second one is something that you would
never see in most generalized
question-answering workshops and that is
having a context of the single sentence
asking what is the translation from
English into German and the output is
again a sequence of words but in this
case and we color them differently here
this is blue because all these words are
basically not in the context and not in
the question and we will just generate
them with a standard softmax
to basically answer this question we can
also ask what is the summary and you can
see that those two in some ways it's
artificial to make them into a natural
language question you could just say
translate or summarize and this is just
like one kind of task token in your
network but actually half of these tasks
it makes sense because the question also
has actually it's different for every
example so this one here is natural
language inference and a lie which
you've covered also where we want to ask
whether two sentences entail each other
or contradict each other or there's some
neutral relationship between them you've
seen a lot of sentiment and this here is
kind of important we actually ask is the
sentence positive or negative versus
just what is the sentiment and what why
that is important is that you see here
in green this answer here actually comes
from a word in the question and if we
formulate it that way we can eventually
do zero SWAT learning where we asked a
new question that was never asked before
for a new set of labels and magically in
some cases it still actually works and
we'll you know ask why we can ask
question that gives the story happy or
sad and it'll still give us an answer
even though we've never given a training
dataset of a bunch of happy and sad
stories so it's kind of zero shot
classification that you get to in some
cases if you formulate your questions in
a way that the answer is part as a word
in the question then we have semantic
role labeling here
so what pass something experienced kind
of a random weird question then we have
zero shot relation extraction who is the
illustrator of cycle of the werewolf we
also have some dialogue state tracking
what is the current state in a dialogue
and the context just keeps on growing
with the dialogue and then we also have
sequel wiki sequel translation task but
not translating into another natural
language translating into a sequel
database query it's actually a super
helpful task there's a you know a lot of
data out there that is stored in
databases if you can access it without
having to ask
somebody who knows how to program sequel
it will make that data available to a
lot more people so they can analyze it
and like business analytics and so on
and then here window grad scheme us
Internet for a resolution some people
call this kind of common sense reasoning
but it's kind of you know mostly just
enough for a resolution trying to
understand in this context what who is
you know the word like who had given
help was it Susan or Joanne and then
based on this context you can kind of
should be able to figure that out and
again here the question is different for
every single example alright great
question so the question is when I ask
is the sentence positive or negative
will it sometimes eventually
accidentally switch to a different one
of the tasks and we actually have a
slide on that and the answer is it's
surprisingly good at knowing how to go
about doing the tasks and where to get
the answer words from and yeah they'll
make more sense in a couple of slides
once we go over the model any other
questions about the question answering
formalisms formula text generation and
the question answer format as well like
tell me a story good question though can
we do text generation like tell me a
story from a random kind of or in this
kind of formalism we don't have that as
a task because largely it's really hard
to evaluate it'll tell you some random
stuff and then is that a good story or
not is it grammatical you have to come
up with a lot of sort of evaluation
metrics which we actually are doing for
some of the dialogue systems in the case
of dialogue why does why are they
equivalent because the context can just
keep on growing and every time the user
said something you basically try to then
predict the next answer in that dialogue
and so I think you could very easily use
this to generate text you basically just
ask tell them like what is you know
what's a good ending of the story and
use maybe start the context with like
two or three words and then you ask the
model to generate more and more words in
the formulas and that will describe in a
second yeah
when you're training and your pregnancy
just like menu class this is like less
data that is a amazing ly thoughtful
question and it's it's so important
we'll have a bunch of slides on it so
maybe we'll we'll go we'll continue and
we'll get to that question and a lot of
detail visits that's sort of why we're
doing it and your short answer is yes
but get to more details all right so
these are basically the ten tasks and
again this is the actual format for it
so if you have a problem and you can
cast it in this format you can just take
the open source code and run it and
it'll work and so when you kind of
analyze and think about what we've done
here in some ways we've taken the tasks
that usually is kind of in your head but
it's not given to the model the model is
just given in input X and the output Y
and almost all of these supervised
systems and instead we're actually
including the tasks in the inputs and
the set of inputs to the model you can
kind of call this meta supervised
learning so again the question is kind
of our task definition for each of these
different tasks the mall has to figure
out itself went to ask the question in
that way that can also figure out itself
when to transfer knowledge from these
other tasks and why is again just the
answer so in some ways it's meta
supervised learning and I'm quite
excited because once you allow the tasks
to be given to the model as input you
kind of decide itself how to go about
solving that particular task and now you
can learn a lot more powerful models so
once we had the data set we thought okay
how do we now solve this problem the
simplest way is you could just say well
I have a big if statement I have a
classifier in the beginning and I
classify if this is a machine
translation task then run my machine
translation model and in general and
Python that would still be just like one
big Python model with a bunch of
statements right and that's not the goal
because then we wouldn't get to any of
the transfer learning and zero shot
capabilities that we're hoping for so we
want to have the model you know wanted
to have the capability to internally
adjust to these different tasks and make
these decisions itself
and basically all of those
considerations and all of those thoughts
led us to this model so before I go into
a little bit more detail I'll just like
sort of give you the high-level overview
again you start with the context you
start you ask a question about that
context document and then we're going to
generate the answer one word at a time
by either pointing to the context and
you've had pointers already right or
Internet works all that great pointing
to a question word or choosing a word
from an external vocabulary with your
standard softmax classifier and we'll
have a pointer switch mechanism that
will kind of choose how much to wait
each of these three generation
mechanisms so let's dig into a little
bit into this model fortunately in some
ways it's kind of just taking the best
of the current sort of state-of-the-art
techniques and putting them together in
a way that that generalized well enough
you can look at all the code on tech NLP
calm it has like thousands of stars and
and forks and stuff combined and you can
you know basically run everything in
this on these experiments with just one
comment it'll double you get all the
datasets and everything and run
everything you can really explore what
it looks like but that's let's dive a
little bit into the details of what this
model hold us in some ways again it just
kind of takes all the best ingredients
from deep learning final P most of which
you've already learned about and puts
them together in a reasonable way so we
start with fixed klav embeddings
eventually we'll we update it the
embeddings to cove embeddings
and probably it'll work even better if
you update them to bert embeddings but
at some point we kind of have to move on
and do other things but basically you
have a fixed set of word vectors and
that is kind of important because in
some of these data sets they're much
smaller than others and as you know from
squad if you actually back propagate
into the word vectors you just do really
well on your training data set but then
you won't generalize because of most of
the text test documents will include
words you've never seen before so if you
change all the word vectors during
training it won't it won't work very
well at test time and won't generalize
to
in words so fixed clever embeddings if
you don't have ward vectors for unseen
words we also have character and
grandmum beddings then we piped them
through a simple linear layer and then
we have a shared by direction LS TM with
skip connections and so it's a deep deep
one so you skip to higher layers and
it's shared between the context and the
questions so they have basically the
same set of ways then we have a Co
attention layer we're basically just
have outer products between all the
hidden states of those two sequences and
again have skipped connections to
circumvent those as well so now you have
kind of context or question dependent
contextual representations or
representations of that context then we
feed those into transformer layers and
we actually tried to use transformers
for all the things with having no LS TMS
or any of that
unfortunately transformer layers were
still very finicky and very hard to
optimize and there's a lot of trickery
with two learning rates and we could
just not get them to perform really well
on on these ten different tasks
sometimes you had one transformer layer
one transformer at Oregon worked really
well in one task but the only other
transformer network that worked well on
the second task had like half the layers
and once you try to have one network
with the same number of layers it just
wouldn't work on either of the two tasks
anymore and so so yeah unfortunately as
nice as they are because they're nicely
paralyzed herbal and GPUs they weren't
yet robust enough to be used for this so
we have to have these LS TMS before and
after the transformer layers and then we
essentially just have a standard sort of
auto regressive decoder we're given the
last state we generate the next word and
then we have these three pointer
mechanisms they're very similar to the
pointer mechanisms you already know but
now on top of these very contextualized
representations at the end of this
encoder and it basically learns to
either point to question words context
words based on the hidden States or have
also a standard softmax and then we just
basically have a weighted sum connect
some of these three different
distributions of output words alright so
I think these are mostly standard
components that you've already saw for
it already seen in all their details but
you have any questions about how we put
together be a word and it's always
either a word from the context or word
from the question or word from the
softmax so the data pre-processing is
different for each task but we basically
have to normalize everything to have the
same two organization and all of that
but the double arrows here are just
bi-directional so left to right and
right to left for the LCM alright so
what data sets are we using I mentioned
that that was a big headache in the
beginning we definitely wanted to
include a lot of the sequence of
sequence tasks that we felt like are
very sort of high level and that
immediately useful and in some ways what
this also shows you is that nowadays you
don't have to work as much on some of
the intermediate representations in NLP
anymore you can just directly go for the
end tasks that real users might care
about and then have these end-to-end
trainable systems that really do quite
well and I've myself worked a lot on
parsing and so I don't want to you know
say we don't need it they're certainly
still tasks that you do need it for but
it's kind of surprising that you can
just go directly to translation or
summarization without having
intermediate representations that were
so very specifically hand designed so we
had those three really interesting and
hard tasks question answering machine
translation summarization they actually
also have the three biggest data sets of
all of these then we had n Li and
basically all of these ten data sets
we're publicly available and
in several cases especially for
translation you could actually find much
larger translation datasets but we also
try to keep it to a size where normal
people that don't work in gigantic
companies with huge GPU infrastructures
could still run experiments themselves
so universities and folks can still run
it on basically if you have just a
single GPU I'll probably take about a
week or so to run an experiment if you
have multiple GPUs on one large AWS
machine you can kind of run an
experiment in a day or two and so
especially for translation right you
could get a lot more data than iw SLT
and each of these communities and data
sets and and tasks has their own metric
we actually try to in the beginning
we've had a lot of discussion about how
we should define the measure of success
for this project it doesn't make sense
to have a normalized f1 score for
basically all the different tasks but
then we basically realized that these
different communities have different
metrics for a reason
unfortunately at least all of these
metrics are from 0 to 100 in theory of
course in practice you rarely ever see a
translation system of a hundred or even
high 90s of a blue score or these really
high root scores but you know in theory
they go from 0 to 100 and so we kept
basically intact the different
evaluation metrics for each of these
communities and we just said we're going
to sum them up and when we first talked
about this we have a lot of discussion
with others also like oh but translation
is so much more important because it's
much bigger and it's much more useful
tasks and you still you know silly like
pronoun resolution winogradsky mas which
only have a couple hundred training
examples and so you should have waited
translation more and then literally five
questions later somebody's like why
didn't you wait pronoun resolution more
that is a really hard task that captures
sort of common sense reasoning and you
know the complexity of language and
semantics and unliked all this like
statistical pattern matching that you do
in translation and I was like you should
talk to that guy and like hopefully in
here and we'll just all agree that it
gets reasonable to sum them up
and of course you also have to tackle
when you run experiments in this a lot
of the complexity that you have in
machine learning and you know stuff that
very few people talk about like having
very skewed distributions so you have
translation which has millions or
hundreds of thousands of examples any of
you new grad schemas that only have a
couple hundred how do you train that
such that you don't just completely
ignore the smaller data set so we'll get
to some of the optimization trickery
that nitish spent several months on in a
bit but I first want to sort of give you
the first set of experiments so as you
can see from all the numbers there's a
lot of experiments that we ran to even
get to this and so we'll walk through
this quite carefully I think hopefully
you'll get some ideas also for for
ablations or experiments that you might
want to run in your in your experiments
and in your problem final final projects
so what are we looking at here so
basically on the left side we have
single task performance so here each
number comes from it's different model
that was trained separately on just one
task each row each column here is the
same architecture and on the right side
here we basically have for each column
is basically the same architecture and
the same exact model so here we have
four different models and here we have
40 different models and each column
again is the same architecture and so
the simplest first column here is just a
standard sequence the sequence model
with very few bells and whistles some
pointers but nothing sort of major it's
pretty deep you know stacked
bi-directional STM script connections
all the standard good well tune stuff
for sequence of sequence models and then
we added self attention this this sort
of basically transformer layers then we
have this KOA tension layer of the outer
products that we mentioned in the
beginning and then we also edit the
question pointer so having the ability
to point to a word in the question all
right any questions about
the state will dig into some of the
details okay well we'll dig into the
details first and maybe you can think of
some questions so let's analyze what's
going on in this table because there are
a lot of numbers and you really want to
carefully analyze and sort of
distinguish I think my first observation
was wow we can have a single
architecture like even even this is not
quite what we want right we were to want
a single model but even this kind of
showed us wow you can have a single
architecture that actually does really
well and somewhat randomly in some cases
it actually had gotten state-of-the-art
results so wiki sequel for instance this
architecture had the best model to
translate natural language English
questions into sequel queries which was
a surprise to us because it is the ninth
data set it was really not like a
priority frost and when we designed the
model and thought about how to generate
words and pointer mechanisms and so on
we just kind of had the standard context
of sequel words and we asked the
question wants a translation to sequel
and then somewhat surprisingly to us
this particular architecture had a state
of the art on sequel generation and a
bunch of folks in that community kind of
picked it up more quickly because it had
state of the art and that's
unfortunately it doesn't have that many
other state-of-the-art numbers which is
why it's harder it's actually a much
harder task and what you also observe is
that in several of the cases using the
multitask model so having a single model
for all the 10 tasks actually hurts
performance at first and this is also
something you rarely read in papers
because papers have a strong selection
bias to only publish positive results
and when you look at most transfer
learning and multitask learning papers
there's sort of an outside of the actual
model consideration of like well let's
only combine tasks that we know will
work well with one another and if they
don't work and hurt performance then we
just exclude them from our experiments
and so you don't see many negative tasks
results in the literature and there are
a few papers here and there that study
basically the opposite side of transfer
learning and that is catastrophic
interference and catastrophic forgetting
so interference is when you train two
different tasks in the same model and to
interfere with one another next you
heard
each other's performance and
catastrophic forgetting is if you train
continually you first train in one task
then you train on a second task people
used to think oh well you know basically
the first task will be completely
forgotten and you just work well on the
second task you have a train a neural
network sort of industry winchell way
one task and then another and someone
surprisingly we we found that things
aren't actually catastrophic ly being
forgotten in these models turns out that
if you train them sequentially and you
add a little bit of the original the
first task it comes back very very
quickly so while the performance is
really bad you can get to the really
good performance very very quickly and
very few iterations so but it's one of
the many interesting sort of tidbits
that we found in the course of this that
we haven't even published yet
all right so focusing on the transformer
layers here we basically find
transformers do help the original
sequence of sequence model a lot so if
you tuned them carefully and you combine
them with some Ella bi-directional STM's
and so on they were very helpful and
improved across a bunch of different
data sets in some cases quite
significantly another observation is
question-answering and semantic role at
role labeling actually can predict each
other's performance quite well if one
works well the other works well and and
vice-versa if they don't work well both
of them don't work very well and it's
also interesting because both of those
tasks have different questions for every
training example pointing so the
question pointing is super-important we
actually have in some cases twice the
performance even for this is kind of
surprising to us a simple classification
task where you could just have a
standard softmax but instead of saying
you have a softness of entailment
contradiction so on you just basically
point to the word entailment in the
question and that was also the case for
Winograd schemas that also benefited a
lot from this pointer mechanism sure can
we explain that why
why does it help so much in some ways I
think partly is the whole architecture
has been gotten has gotten better and
better at pointing and part of the
reason we actually do very very poorly
in translation which is the only task
that hurt in that our first experiments
a lot in the multitask setting is that
that is the only task that now has to
generate results from a completely
separate softmax whereas the rest of the
architecture got really really good at
pointing to things to answer questions
any kind of question and so but in some
ways I think that is one explanation but
I don't think it's it's all of it I
think we still need to figure out more
why this happens all right now multitask
learning is the most helpful when it
comes to zero shot and I'm actually very
excited about that so this is a zero
shot relation extraction where you have
different kinds of relations that you
might want to extract and you've might
have never seen like the student-teacher
relationship that you're trying to
identify in a certain context or a
product company relationship or
something like that
and so that one actually benefitted a
lot and almost got twice as high in
terms of the accuracy when you learned
it with everything else so these were
questions it's never seen before
relations that it's never seen before
and it got twice as good and benefited a
lot especially from having seen other
kinds of questions and in some ways we
have to give a lot of credit to squad
two cuz squad as a dataset kind of
pushed people into thinking about
pointers as a mechanism to generate
answers and pointers we kind of see them
like as a given and they don't get that
much credit but they allow you to
predict answers that you've never seen
before a training time to generate words
you've never seen before a training time
which is actually quite quite amazing
all right now the main observation
though here is that you still if you had
an Oracle that would tell you exactly
which task you're currently in and you
would be perfectly kind of separating
these into ten
different models maybe they're all the
same architecture but there's still 10
different models then you would actually
still do slightly better than the first
version of this multitask learning model
and that is largely because we chose to
include a bunch of different tasks that
have nothing to do with one another and
we wanted the community to start
thinking about tackling catastrophic
interference all right if you learn like
a new language or you know you learn how
to understand social media on Twitter
you don't replace all your language you
know and your brain you have one brain
it keeps getting smarter you keep
learning new skills even when the skills
that are new to you are very very
different from old skills so in some
ways we may have made our lives too hard
and now we're actually thinking okay
maybe if we want to publish a nicer
paper and multitask learning we just
look at all the tasks that do help each
other and then we'll just you know have
groups of tasks and then you can very
quickly publish some some nice
state-of-the-art papers but basically
here we're still quite significantly
away in the DECA score between ten
different models and a single model now
this of course is kind of an Oracle
score that's why we put it in
parentheses because you don't actually
have this Oracle and in some cases it's
quite easy to build an almost perfect
classifier so you know separating what
is the summary based on that question
and what is the translation from English
to German you can do with almost 10%
accuracy but Squad a question answering
and zero shot relation extraction and
question answering as a semantic role
labeling those are actually easily
confused in terms of how to generate the
answers and you wouldn't quite know
which into which model to route this so
in some sense this is kind of
theoretical all right now I mentioned
that we have this process this
complexity in the optimization strategy
and this is one of the many sort of
problems that don't get that much
coverage but when you have a very
imbalanced or skewed data set it's easy
to lose track and basically overpower
the smaller data set tasks and so
the first simplest trainings really
tried a ton of different strange
training strategies but in the end this
fully joint one worked quite well but I
actually promised us go wait for
questions on this table so any questions
on all these results so far yeah tell
you which task it is so did you try
training a model on like determining
what tasks we did and so it confused you
know squad and and those to the question
the other basically the other two types
of problems that were also cast ask
question answering so it confused those
but then a lot of the others there was
able to come like very perfectly do it
but then you basically as soon as you
were to try to then build a whole model
and get a Decker score if your if your
classifier is even like 90% accurate you
basically multiply this by 0.9 and you
get things so hard that it's not
competitive anymore so it is actually
hard if you try to just build that whole
system and keep adding sort of
if-then-else statements to make that
into sort of a single system telling the
mobile what kind of I mean in some ways
we did in this case because we only
trained each model separately on it only
through the question in some cases you
could tell so the question is sort of in
even in the multi test setting you could
have like an extra kind of token to say
now you're doing summarization so that's
another input in some ways whether you
have a summarization token or you ask
what is the summary it actually I don't
think makes that big of a difference
it's just now you can query this model
in very natural language rather than
having to know kind of a special token
to query the model and we'll see
actually in a couple slides that the
model is not confused
when it comes to how to generate the
answer so for every of the tasks it
knows very clearly how to generate the
words to get to the right to get to you
know a reasonably accurate answer
questions so how do we train the single
task models there are only trained on
that data set so the squad number here
is just a single model it has only seen
squad training somewhat surprisingly
even in the case here where we had Oasis
multi nli this particular model I mean
if you just have the standard sequence
of sequence it just generates you know
also with softmax that label so in that
sense it's quite similar but yeah it was
actually better able to just point which
actually led us for awhile into thinking
about maybe we should have a project
where we just say point to all the
things and just get rid of softmax
classifiers forever the problem is when
you didn't try to do translation also
it's like okay wow what are you point to
and then you kind of pre train it you do
some alignment and it gets kind of very
large and you point a lot of different
light you may have like like tens of
thousands of potential candidates so we
kind of discarded as like a single
unifying model for all the things but
you could point to a lot of different
like a lot of these tasks you could
actually point to and I think it's
another interesting side project that
could spawn from this yeah
just as quick question how how sensitive
water issues test how sensitive the
individual performance across class was
when you started the trip the relative
weights of them so we the question is
how sensitive were to task if we were to
add weights to the different tasks we
did in the optimization kind of did a
lot of trickery on how to Train it but
we never said this task only matters
like 0.5 or something so we didn't do
that analysis in some cases yeah I mean
these are all deficits but it's you
could definitely do even more
architecture engineering in fact there's
this whole field which I don't think
you've gotten to right our neural
architecture search yeah so like you can
actually combine your reinforcement
learning and you say the action space
for the reinforcement learning agent are
trying to have a couple of different
modules of neural nets like maybe you
want to have like a CNN layer and then
like a memory layer and then an lsdm
layer and maybe it's bi-directional and
you'd basically let a reinforcement
learning agent figure out all of these
decisions so I think it would be
phenomenal to try to apply neural
architecture search not to what's
usually being done which is we already
know how to do image classification we
just do it slightly better with NES and
roll architecture search but we actually
try to find a single architecture for
multi task learning which we don't know
the problem of course is that already
getting to these all these numbers took
a lot of compute time and a lot of
fiddling around with stuff and it is I
can I can only give you sort of an idea
of like how often we would say oh man we
got like as really amazing result in
this task but it needed this learning
rate and it turns out the same model
same set of hyper parameters everything
but this other task to get to good
performance needed a much higher
learning rate and now you try to combine
those two tasks only together and you're
like okay how do you choose your
learning rate now you choose you know if
you choose to pass the learning rate
from the task that is you know bigger
then the smaller task just doesn't work
well
at all because it needed this higher
learning rate if you use the higher
learning rate that the smaller tasks and
smaller data set did really well on then
the large one just over fits and doesn't
work well either if you try to do the
average neither of the two work like
there's a lot of complexity in trying to
do multi task learning that's why that's
why it's such an interesting I think
research challenge any more question
about these first set of results they
get they will get better we have we have
had some ideas already on on how to
improvement alright so how do we
actually train this whole thing we had
tried a lot of different things but in
the end this very simple fully joint
training strategy actually worked the
best and that is you basically take a
mini batch from each of the different
tasks and you just train on that mini
batch from that task so basically just
going through all the 10 tasks and then
round-robin go through them now it turns
out that that does not work quite as
well as another straining strategy and
if you look into optimization strategies
and neural nets they're actually a
couple of papers on so-called curriculum
learning where the idea is you start
with training your model with simple
prop simple instances or your problems
so in translation for instance you start
training with very short sentences and
then you go to larger and larger
sentences or a longer longer sentences
now it turns out for multi task learning
you actually want to do the opposite you
want to do anti curriculum learning and
that is you start with the hardest task
and you iterate on those for awhile and
then you add the simple tasks later on
and to some degree I think this is
intuitive because when you train this
very gigantic and powerful model on a
very simple task like sentiment and you
just need to classify everything to be
positive or negative you train all of
these weights and you arrive in sort of
local optima that are quite deep and
very specific to just generating these
two words and if you then try to get out
of it out of this local optimum
that very simple task and then try to
generate all these other kinds of words
and point to different you know words
that's never seen before
lynch squad it's very very hard to come
out of that local optimum and that is
sort of my intuition of why it actually
makes more sense to say let's start with
squad and machine translation and a
couple of these harder tasks make the
model very general purpose has to
generate a lot of different things
created softmax you know
german words it has to point to all
kinds of different words and be able to
parse all kinds of different wikipedia
paragraphs and you do that a couple of
times and then once you've finished this
sort of pre training stage or anti
curriculum then you move on and add sort
of the simpler or smaller tasks so with
that relatively simple change that did
take us a lot of different experiments
to get to we actually closed or went
closer to closing that gap and now we're
only sort of 14 away right yeah 14 or so
but there's still a big gap and the
biggest nuisance an issue that we had
was with a translation basically if you
look at all of these most things are
kind of similar or get slightly better
and it's sort of a toss-up but then and
and roughly similar but translation was
really bad it's almost only half the
performance in the multitask learning
setup and part of that is because
translation was the only task that had a
very large softmax vocabulary of words
that were in no other task and most of
the other tasks actually were doing
really well with pointing and so my
interpretation of this was that the
intermediate layers all these
representations that we learned with by
directional STM's and transformers they
got really really good at being pointed
to like creating hidden representations
that the answer module can point to very
accurately and then you have this one
task that is like I don't point to
almost anything I basically just
generate other words in a different
vocabulary and so those hidden
representations became less useful for
that task
and so that was one of the insights and
that led to one of the ways of trying to
improve this now one of the interesting
issues that we had is when we improved
the model the multi single model for all
10 tasks a lot of times we said well but
now we also have to go back and run ten
more experiments on all the single tasks
to have a proper comparison right
because if you tuned the thing you care
about and you stop tuning the thing you
want to show you can do better than then
that's not fair
so you always want to give as much TLC
and in focus and experiment time to your
baselines and so in some cases we
actually improve some improved something
but then we improve both the ten
separate models and our model in some
cases like the ten separate models
improve even more so the gap got even
larger to kind of the opposite of what
we wanted to show but in general it's
better for multitask of for the
architecture overall so basically we
started with this fully joint training
and we have this sort of set of single
models that we could in theory with some
Oracle kind of just sum up in their
scores to get a deco score so the gap
started at 23 and then we basically did
this entire human training which lowered
the gap to 15 so we're kind of excited
making good progress then we switched
from glove and use Cove
so contextual vectors which actually
increase the gap a lot again so
everything got better but the ten
separate models got even better than the
one single model did does the 10 tasks
so the gap got bigger but everybody's
performance increased so it was still
overall a good thing and then we
basically figured especially with this
machine translation issue we shouldn't
just pre train on squad but we also
should include machine translation in
this pre training in the beginning so
the model doesn't just start learning to
point and that helped us to reduce the
gap between the ten separate models
Oracle and the single model to about
five points and then we basically said
okay translation is still not that good
we just keep over sampling so every time
we go through
one of these round-robin mini-batch sets
we just always include machine
translation and that basically allowed
us to then reduce the gap to just a
single point so now we started coupled
with several months ago at 586 and now
the single Oracle with ten different
models if you were to sum them up get
618 and the you know better contextual
vectors and tuning and adding a lot more
translation and mid translation is still
not as good as we would like it to be
but now a several of the other tasks
benefited a bunch and now we're
basically one take a score away from
having a single model that does as well
as ten different ones and you can
basically you could run even more
experiments in some ways you could burn
millions of dollars on AWS cost here
because most of the time we kept the
hyper parameters of these different
models the same like each of these you
could also say well maybe this multitask
model needs to have 50 more layers or
maybe 19 more layers or maybe five more
layers and maybe they should be a
thousand you know wider and their hidden
dimensions and you could basically run a
lot more experiments maybe hopefully
eventually the community jointly does
that and then we can kind of move move
towards that but we figured okay we're
pretty close so we moved on to some
other things which maybe I'll tell you
about next year but basically let's do
some analysis of what happened in this
project and this is kind of I think
something that I would encourage you all
to do as well
like you you can chase the numbers for a
while and in some ways you should always
be skeptical about your evaluations and
in some cases you've seen or we've seen
in the NLP community people like
basically just optimized blue scores for
translation for years and then somebody
came out with a paper and said well it
turns out blue metrics and human
evaluations on how good of a translation
is this aren't actually that correlated
and you're like oh that that sucks we
just spend years of our lives tuning
that metric and publishing a bunch of
papers and so in some ways all of these
metrics have flaws you know Rouge score
summarization is a super subjective
of tasks and in summarization for
instance when you analyze the errors you
often realize that word vectors have
problems too so for instance a word
vector for Jason John and Jeremy are all
kind of the same right they all have
similar distribution similar contexts
windows and so on and so word vectors of
names are very similar and so in
summarization errors you realize oh well
you know this article's news article
talked about Jeremy being kidnapped but
the summary said Jason was kidnapped you
like well you know in the evaluation
metric that's just one word is off and
like all the rest is correct but it's
pretty important word and so word
vectors have like issues for
summarization that are pretty
fundamental and I don't think anybody is
tackling really well right now
so all of these metrics have issues I
would argue though that combining the
ten actually makes it less problematic
and more meaningful than looking at each
one separately because now you can't use
the idiosyncrasies of one particular
evaluation metric to just get like your
score a little bit higher because then
if you just tune with that particular
thing in mind it will hurt some of the
other tasks and you won't get to this
sort of general NLP model that much more
easily alright so now let's do some
analysis of this model and look at and
this is kind of thing comes to one the
question that was asked is the model
able to kind of generate the right words
for the right task and here we basically
looked at the distributions of how often
the model generated words and it's
different with these three different
mechanisms softmax vocabulary context
pointers or question pointers and as you
can see in the majority of cases it
knows exactly how to generate so for
question answering a semantic role
labeling and squad and wiki sequel and
summarization it basically uses the
context pointer so it just points into
the context document and we know for
squad that is basically how the data set
was generated so that's the only thing
that that really makes a lot of sense
what's kind of cool is that in some
cases like summarization it sometimes
creates new words or you know
weren't in the context document weren't
pointed to and four zero shot relation
extraction also sometimes uses this
external vocabulary and in some cases
the context pointer so for the most part
this model doesn't is not confused how
to execute on a task given this question
formalism rather than the format of sort
of this is the task just do with this
particular task now you might argue ok
I'm not that impressed by you know
having the performance be slightly the
same with one model versus ten separate
models even though it's nice if you want
to deploy it right it's like uses less
ram and all of that assuming they're the
same size or you know one-tenth the size
but what I'm excited about is more like
the next couple of results and namely
sort of this transfer learning domain
adaptation and zero shot these kinds of
capabilities so here we chose two data
sets that weren't included in the
original ten and we basically trained a
pre trained model on this versus a
random model and randomly here again
they're the same architecture and pre
train means the entirety of the model
was pre trained all the you know
encoders including the decoder and the
softmax and everything and the two other
tasks were another I WS LT language pair
namely translating from the English to
check and named entity recognition test
you all know very well so basically what
we found is that it converges much more
quickly in the beginning and then
there's still a significant but not
gigantic gap so there's pre training on
these completely separate kinds of tasks
had helped and I think that's that's
pretty exciting especially sort of the
quicker convergence like learning more
quickly whatever new tasks you you come
up with which also means in some cases
you can get away with less training data
on these new on these new tasks now
domain adaptation is kind of the simpler
form of transfer learning where you
basically just have a different type of
you know distribution for your words we
mentioned we have the Stanford sentiment
tree Bank for sentiment analysis
and then we analyze this on different
sentiment datasets namely Amazon product
reviews and Yelp restaurant reviews and
out of the box without any training the
malla just got a percent accuracy on
both of those data sets and I think for
practitioners that is pretty exciting
because you basically didn't have to
Train anything it just kind of worked
out of the box downloaded from github
and run it I said no I was slightly
different it didn't quite work as well
it's another natural language inference
dataset but has very different very
different distribution different kinds
of domains that these entailment
questions are asked over and here out of
the box it achieved 62 but then once you
fine-tune it and similar to these
experiments here continue to actually
train on this data set it quickly
converts to 87 which was still 2% gain
over randomly initialized dynamic and
model yeah
did you evaluate how much did you get
away with did we evaluate how much less
data we can get away with we didn't and
in some ways whenever you would run this
experiment you'd basically be like you'd
still not do as well like everything all
these models will still do better with
more training data so you just kind of
it would be a fuzzy kind of say like
fuzzy sort of result right where you say
well with one tenth we might get to 50
and the other model might get only 240
blues or something like that but yeah we
don't hide on that post numbers would be
kind of actually also needs need
analysis to do so do we have the code to
train a new task yes we do
you can just edit make it into this
format using context here's a question
simple like CSV type format and then you
add it and you can both like train the
pre train them all yourselves you can
download a pre train model and just add
it don't get up yeah using other types
of refrain representations like saver
so it's a great question so how does
this compare to other pre-trained
representations like Bert's so in some
ways people say Bert is kind of this
model that does everything but when you
actually read the paper you realize well
it it's a separate model for these
different tasks right if you want to
have a classification task you have a
little token in the beginning and you
have a different top layer if you want
to do a sequence labeling task you have
a different top layer if you want to do
a sequence extraction task you have a
different top layer so Bert isn't
actually a single model for all of these
different tasks and then on all the
results there's a lot of extra tuning
for each of the data sets and tasks that
you know different learning rate for
this task different size they're
different sets of bird and so on so
we're also super exciting with like
maybe this is it we'll just run
everything on Bert and then we looked
into all the details and there's so much
exciting in the beginning and then the
more we dug through the details the less
excited we became as this being like
sort of the answer because it is not a
single model in some ways it's probably
better for pre training so instead of
Cove you can have kind of Bert at the
very beginning and my hunch is
everything will get slightly better but
you still need to have a lot of the a
lot of the other sort of modeling
architecture on top of it and then the
sad thing is to really get the
state-of-the-art results there's a lot
of various tasks specific tuning who's
those last top layers so if you try to
unify that task specific tuning you lose
a lot of the good performance of Bert so
unfortunately it's not quite the sort of
I'll just use bird for it and you'll
just have state of the art numbers and
all things I could probably go like talk
about a lot more but I think it still
makes sense to think about some of the
ideas from bird like basically add as
one of the tasks language modeling that
would be very likely the task that helps
the most for all the other tasks and we
should include that it also would be
nice to have a faster model right now
it's hard to do language modeling is
very very large at benefits even more
from you know billions and billions of
words it's hard to train the Macan model
this current question-answering model
with the code
mechanism of the question with like an
increasingly large context so you'd have
to kind of split it also like bird works
also reasonably well only for like at
most I think 500 words or so and if you
wanted to do summarization basically
have to cut the original document to
only 500 words and then try to summarize
it so there a lot of like devil in the
details that they didn't have to figure
out because they said well we'll just
sort of just like word vectors we can
take them in and then we do a lot of
other stuff that is task specific with
those those wor vectors or with the bird
architecture I still I don't want this
part is obviously amazing and we are
looking into trying to use ideas from it
but unfortunately it wasn't just sort of
a silver bullet to solve multitask
learning consider how much loss there is
sorry did we
so did we consider prioritizing the
sampling so in some ways with this
pre-training strategy here that's kind
of what we did by basically focusing on
these really hard tasks and a lot of
like the gap in the end was improved by
really waiting for like four of the
tasks at the very end and you know until
after you're gone through sort of over
sampling all of these really hard tasks
in the last 10 minutes basically the
most exciting thing for last though I
think you could also do a lot more work
in this direction
I mentioned this whole question pointer
and zero for learning in the beginning
and we basically just tried to play
around with that a little bit and found
that in some cases it actually kind of
magically works so here we tried a
sentence John had a party but no one
came and he was all alone and then we
asked is this story sad or happy and
while the model could have you know
generate some random German words or
some random sequel words or just said
you know whatever it actually pointed to
of all the words he could have pointed
to in the context or the question that
pointed to set which is pretty cool like
and it's just one
all sample and you know you could do a
lot more you could try to come up with a
very large zero shot kind of
classification data set which is
actually kind of hard to you have to be
quite creative it's not like you can
just say oh we'll just take all these
reviews and label them as these you know
positive negative but so I think we we
need to do more work in that direction
somebody will hopefully create a zero
shot kind of tasks dataset that is not
just your shot for you know sort of new
distributions or something with
completely different outputs but we
tried a couple and it doesn't always
work right you can be adversarial about
it you can make this basically looks
most similar to is the sentiment
positive or negative is the sentence
it's this sentence positive or negative
that was the formalism we had for
sentiment analysis and so you could if
you make the question more and more
different eventually it'll kind of get
tripped up and it's clear that it's
benefitted from the word vectors of sad
being closer to negative and then
understanding sort of through all these
correlations and and deep
representations that there are other
sort of sad words in this context or
whatever it is and so I was able to
point to this but you can be adversarial
it doesn't always work but even the fact
that it was sort of zero shot
classification based on word vectors for
new kinds of questions personally was
very exciting to me and we tried a
couple of other things like Brian gave a
talk and nobody clapped was Brian happy
or sad and it also got it right so there
are a couple a couple of the examples
where we're at least as happy or sad
thing worked and then a couple of others
sort of adjective questions that we we
tried but what I'm what I would be most
excited about is eventually actually
trying to have a zero shot
classification task that combines the
different tasks - so unfortunately
there's no data set for that so we
didn't train it so it doesn't happen
with the model but in theory if you
asked what is this time you can
summarize and you can translate from
English into German
why can you ask the model for German
summary and if that worked eventually
that would be even more amazing but it
doesn't work right now because we never
asked it sort of for these compositional
tasks these compositional task questions
but is yet another interesting line of
research
I think could spawn from this all right
so I hope I could show you that this
sort of Decca NLP framework is an
interesting new benchmark for
generalized NLP I do think it's a
reasonably good framework for tackling a
bunch of the really hard questions in
the field more general language
understanding and question answering of
course multitask learning domain
adaptation which we sort of analyzed a
little bit with the sentiment and SLI
versus multi nli transfer learning and
then weight sharing I think it's clear
everybody loves weight sharing you want
to share as many weights as possible
word vectors started it Elmo
Cove and Albert basically share more and
more deeper and deeper layers it would
be great if we can unify that last bit
also and then share basically the
entirety of the networks and then
eventually hopefully get to zero short
learning now there's a bunch of related
work the original paper has over 100
citations in it of you know papers to
other other lines of work but this is
actually either at least some of the
models and papers that influence us the
most in our thinking and modeling one of
them actually comes from the two
instructors of the class and so
hopefully we can you know sort of think
about what what's next after all this
architecture engineering and I think one
potential answer to that is single
multitask learning for more generalized
NLP mods thank you
you